let's actually just explore we touched
it a little bit but just on the art the
science and the Art of programming uh
for you personally how much of your
programming is done with GPT currently
none none I think at all
because you prioritize simplicity so
much
yeah I find that a lot of it is noise I
do use vs code
um and I do like some amount of
autocomplete I do like like a very um a
very like Feels Like rules based
autocomplete like an autocomplete it's
going to complete the variable name for
me so I'm going to type it I can just
press tab right that's nice but I don't
want it autocomplete you know what I
hate when Auto completes when I type the
word for and it like puts like two two
parentheses and two semicones and two
braces I'm like
what I mean with the vs code and GPT
with codex you can um
you can kind of brainstorm I I find
I'm like probably the same as you but I
like that it generates code and you
basically disagree with it and write
something simpler but to me that somehow
is like inspiring it makes me feel good
it's also gamifies the simplification
process because I'm like oh yeah you
dumb AI system you think is the way to
do it as I have a simpler thing here it
just constantly reminds me of like like
bad stuff I mean I tried the same thing
with rap right I tried the same thing
with rap and I actually think I'm a much
better programmer than rapper but like I
even tried I was like okay can we get
some inspiration from these things for
some rap lyrics
found that it would go back to the most
like cringy tropes and dumb rhyme
schemes and I'm like yeah this is what
the code looks like too
I I think you and I probably have
different thresholds for clinch code
they probably hate cringe code
so it's for you
I mean uh
boilerplate as a part of code
like some of it
yeah and some of it is just like faster
lookup
because I don't know about you but I
don't remember everything like I don't
I'm offloading so much of my memory
about like
um yeah different functions Library
functions all that kind of stuff like
this GPS is very fast at standard stuff
and like uh standard Library stuff basic
stuff that everybody uses
yeah I think that
I don't know I mean there's just a
little of this in Python
maybe if I was coding more in other
languages I would consider it more but I
feel like python already does such a
good job of removing any boilerplate
that's true it's
then get to pseudocode right yeah that's
true that's true and like yeah sure if I
like yeah I'm great GPT thanks for
reminding me to free my variables
unfortunately you didn't really
recognize the scope correctly and you
can't free that one but like you put the
freeze there and like I get it
Fiverr whatever I've used Fiverr for
certain things like design or whatever
yeah it's always you come back I think
that's probably closer my experience
with Fiverr is close to your experience
with programming with GPT is like you're
just frustrating feel worse about the
whole process of design and art and
whatever whatever I use five or four
still I just feel like later versions
GPT I I'm using
um
GPT as much as possible
to just learn the Dynamics of it like
these early versions because it feels
like in the future you'll be using it
more and more
and so like I don't want to be like for
the same reason I gave away all my books
and switched to Kindle because like all
right how long are we gonna have paper
books like 30 years from now like I want
to learn to be reading on on Kindle even
though I don't enjoy it as much and you
learn to enjoy it more in the same way I
switched from
let me just pause I switch from emacs to
vs code yeah I switched from Vim to vs
code I think I similar but yeah it's
tough and that's Vim to vs code is even
tougher because emacs is like
old like more outdated feels like it the
community is more outdated Vim is like
pretty vibrant still so I never used any
of the plugins I still don't use it
that's what I looked at myself in the
mirror I'm like yeah you wrote some
stuff in lisp yeah but I never used any
of the plugins in Vim either I had the
most vanilla Vim I have a syntax
eyeliner I didn't even have autocomplete
like these things
I feel like help you so marginally
that like
and now okay now vs codes autocomplete
has gotten good enough that like okay I
don't have to set it up I can just go
into any code base and auto completes
right 90 of the time okay cool I'll take
it
all right so I don't think I'm gonna
have a problem at all adapting to the
tools once they're good but like the
real thing that I want is not
something that like tab completes my
code and gives me ideas the real thing
that I want is a very intelligent pair
programmer that
uh comes up a little pop-up saying hey
you wrote a bug on line 14 and here's
what it is
yeah now I like that you know what does
a good job with this my pie
I love my mind my pipe is fancy type
checker for python yeah
um and actually I tried like Microsoft
released one too and it was like
60 false positives my pie is like five
percent false positives 95 of the time
it recognizes I didn't really think
about that typing interaction correctly
thank you my pie so you like uh type
hinting you liked you like pushing the
language towards towards being a typed
language oh yeah absolutely I think I
think optional typing is is great
I think that like it's like a meet in
the middle right like python has these
optional type hinting and like C plus
has Auto
C plus plus six allows you to take a
step back well C plus plus would have
you brutally type out STD string
iterator right now I can type Auto which
is nice and then python used to just
have
a what type is a
it's an a yeah
um a colon Str oh okay it's a string
cool yeah I wish there were I wish there
was a way like a simple way in Python to
uh like turn on a mode which would
enforce the types
yeah they give a warning when there's no
type something like this well no to give
a warning where like my pilot is a
static type Checker but I'm asking just
for a runtime Checker like there's like
ways to like hack this in but I wish it
was just like a flag like python3-t
oh I see yeah I see enforce the types
are one time yeah I feel like that makes
you a better programmer that that's a
kind of test right that the the type can
the type Remains the Same well that I
know that isn't like messenger types up
but again like my pie is getting really
good and I love it
um and I can't wait for some of these
tools to become AI powered like I want
AIS reading my code and giving me
feedback I don't want AIS
writing half-assed autocomplete stuff
for me I wonder if you can now take GPT
and give it a code that you wrote for
function and say how can I make this
simpler and have it accomplish the same
thing
I think you'll get some good ideas on
some code you maybe not the code you
right
um for tiny grad type of code because
that requires so much design thinking
but like other kinds of code I don't
know I downloaded the plugin maybe like
two months ago I tried it again and
found the same look I don't doubt that
these models are going to first become
useful to me then be as good as me and
then surpass me
but
from what I've seen today it's like it's
like like
someone you know occasionally taking
over my keyboard that I hired from
Fiverr yeah
ideas about how to debug the code or
basically a better debugger is really
interesting I mean but it's not a better
debugger I guess I would love a better
debugger yeah it's not yet yeah but it
feels like it's not too far yeah one of
my co-workers says he uses them for
print statements like every time you
have to like just like when he needs the
only thing it can really write is like
okay I just want to write the thing to
like print the state out right now
oh that definitely is much faster his
print statements yeah yeah I see myself
using that a lot just like because it it
figures out the rest of the functions
just like okay print everything yeah
print everything right and then yeah
like if you want a pretty printer maybe
I'm like you know what I think like I
think in two years I'm gonna start using
these plugins yeah a little bit and then
in five years I'm gonna be heavily
relying on some AI augmented flow and
then in 10 years do you think you'll
ever get to 100 percent
where the like what's the role of the
human that it converges to
as a programmer
so you think it's all generated
our Niche becomes I think it's over for
humans in general
it's not just programming it's
everything
well orange becomes smaller smaller
Smart in fact I'll tell you what the
last niche of humanity is going to be
yeah
um there's a great book and it's if I
recommended metamorphosis Prime
intellect last time there is a sequel
called a casino Odyssey in cyberspace
and um
they don't want to give away the ending
of this but it tells you what the last
remaining human currency is and I agree
with that
we'll uh leave that as the Cliffhanger
uh
so no more programmers left huh
that's where we're going well unless you
want handmade code maybe they'll sell it
on Etsy this is handwritten code
doesn't have that machine polished to it
it has the slight imperfections that
would only be written by a person